alors à ce jour l'épidémie a déjà fait
13 morts en asie elle reste mystérieuse
par précaution l'europe se mobilise donc
des spécialistes sont réunis à rome et
la france envisagent tous les scénarios
y compris celui d'une épidémie à
l'échelle de la planète d'attali sa
peine à rémy poissonnier provient de
chief in situ mais on avoir été inquiet
parce que clairement pour éviter de
consommer du poulet
j'ai eu mon frère au téléphone bon
j'étais ce que j'essaie ils sont bloqués
là-bas pendant trois heures
parce que les tests étaient confrontés
ça et c'est pour ça que l'avion ça fait
6 à 15 ans atteint depuis six ans qu'on
a changé l'approché tout est bien
maîtrisé son sol au demeurant ça me sens
bien
hachez qu'en effet pas d'inquiétude
encore moins de psychose
la grippe du poulet n'affole pas les
voyageurs mais au plus haut niveau de
l'état
la menace est prise très au sérieux
comme le strat l'année dernière un plan
d'urgence est en préparation qui
mobilise de nombreux acteurs notamment
les médecins
un peu de sang ce généraliste parisien
fait partie du réseau sentinelles 1200
médecins sur tout le territoire qui
surveille les principales maladies
depuis peu ce médecin a reçu une mission
particulière détecter l'arrivée en
france des éventuels premiers cas de
grippe nous envoyer une note nous
précisant les symptômes devant lesquels
nous devons nous méfier si je voyais
quelqu'un avec les yeux rouges larmoyant
accompagné d'une forte fièvre de la toux
le nez qui coule un malaise général je
devrai me méfier ce réseau sentinelles
va être renforcée dans la perspective
d'une épidémie chez l'homme de la grippe
du poulet
car tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de
repérer l'entrée du virus sur le
territoire français si on arrive très
tôt on peut circonscrire très rapidement
les foyers épidémiques
si l'on arrive trop tard alors parfois
les transmissions se sont déroulés et
les processus sont difficiles à enrayer
si un cas arrivée en france de grippe
aviaire il faudrait évidemment isolé ce
cas et pour le protéger et le traiter au
mieux il n'y aurait pas a priori pas
aujourd'hui à notre connaissance de riz
de transmission pour l'instant ce sont
les oiseaux qui transmettent le virus à
l'homme
c'est pourquoi les oiseaux sauvages qui
peuvent transport transporter ce virus
vont également être contrôlés